[music playing]
Oh, dammit, slipped chain.
[exhales] I hate these.
Small limbs like that, it
happens with chain saws.
I got to fix this up.
The fun ain't over yet.
[engine revving]
OK.
I got my poles.
Time to get to work.
What I want to do is
get this bark off.
Then I'm going to make a point
and drive it in the ground.
One of the benefits of
living in the woods,
you got to be creative.
If you're not creative,
you're going to struggle.
[banging]
Try to use a little bit
of caveman knowledge
to make things a little
more comfortable.
I'm able to survive out here.
But I want to thrive
out here, too.
OK.
Bench is done.
Woo, hoo, hoo!
You guys want to check it
out and have some hot choc?
KIDS: Yeah.
SON: That's cooler
than I expected.
RICK DEWILDE: It's awesome, huh?
SON: Yeah.
We got our rocks.
We got our cottonwood.
We got our bench, nice backrest.
You see how this thing is?
Look.
See how it just smolders?
Before Western society came,
before there was matches,
and lighters, and stuff, this
is how back in the day people
carried their spark.
Because believe me,
no matter how good
you are at making a
fire, you wouldn't be
able to make one at 50 below.
And without this spark,
without this birch punk
right here, easily we
could not be here today.
We'd be wiped out, extinct
in this area of the Earth.
Whatever created us
and created the earth
made it possible with
tools like this growing
right on the trees.
So that's good to
think about, you know.
I know what was my
favorite part of the day.
What?
This.
This is your favorite part.
Good one.
Now that these gnats are
gone, we got the perfect spot.